foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
No Labels my ass
it's called Traders that's what it is
that's the label that you would give no
labels
you know I think a lot of people are
freaking out about this I know Lincoln
project is really yelling and screaming
at the top of their lungs about No
Labels this morning it seems like Joe
manchin is going to speak at several uh
the events
Chris Kirsten Cinema the once Senator
she's not going to be a senator of
Arizona anymore she's not going to be a
senator
she abandoned the people who helped her
get elected like the literal people who
went and stumped for her went door to
door knocked door to door for her she
abandoned them not just the constituents
like the people who did the work to get
her elected who volunteered she gave
them the big [__] you
she won't be a United States Senator
she won't be
she won't be now
a lot of people this morning are talking
about no labels and who is funding it
and of course one of the names that
comes out of the mix is Harlan Hitler
most people know him as Harlan Crow but
here on the Tony Michaels podcast we
defame people by calling them Harlan
Hitler and the reason why is because he
has a signed copy of mine comp hey
Harlan send me a c d [__]
do it you got enough money you could you
could totally destroy me do it
Harlan Hitler apparently is one of the
funders of No Labels maybe I don't know
he definitely is trying to get tax
breaks by buying Supreme Court Justices
apparently
it seems he was trying to write off his
buy-offs of Clarence Thomas
I mean they're vacations that you're
buying Supreme Court that's a business
expense isn't it to buy a Supreme Court
Justice to make sure
that the decision goes in the way of
your financial future I mean what's
what's a few hundred million dollars if
you're going to get a few billion
dollars in return for a decision from
Supreme Court Justices right I mean
that's a pretty good investment and
being an investment don't you think you
should get some tax cuts rich people do
okay
you know I giggle about it but it's
exactly where we're at
and [__] are running around
going oh but Democrats are demons
yeah okay are you paying attention
speaking of paying attention the uh I
watched a video of Leslie Jones this
morning of the SAG
a lot of people aren't paying attention
to what's going on with the writers and
the actors strike
and I told you this last week when the
when this when they announced it
that people would be like oh their
actors make so much money and I was like
don't buy into that [__]
don't buy into this line where the
actors are the the ones who make all the
money in Hollywood are the ones trying
to get more money no it is the actors
that make the most that are standing
with the actors that make the least
that's how it's supposed to work
if you're successful in a business
really successful and you're part of a
union and you're one of the most
successful union members you should
stand with the union members that aren't
as successful that's the whole point
that's the point
you shouldn't disparage
the people of your business that are in
the lower tier of pay when you're in
that business too
it's the corporations that are making
all the money off the backs of the
writers and the actors yes some actors
make a lot of money in Hollywood
some of them are super rich and those
are the ones that are standing with the
people who aren't the corporations are
saying ah [__] you we're not paying you
[__]
you got the wrong bad guy okay you got
the wrong bad guy
when you're going after the actors who
who have seen some success and by
success a lot of it is a really a high
amount of success that is true a lot of
these actors and producers in Hollywood
they're actors directors writers all in
them themselves
producers some of them have Studios
right
like Brad Pitt has plan B several others
have other production companies where
they produce their video or their their
movies
their television shows look those are
few and far between in the business just
look at how much [__] content is on
Netflix alone
I was watching um a video with uh Adam
Conover and Adam ruins everything uh
he's been at the Forefront of the writer
strike and he was on a Sean Pike or
Assan Abby's uh twitch stream and he was
talking about his his the difference
between the shows that he's produced one
of them was Adam ruins everything on
True TV True TV is a very small channel
on cable one of the smallest channels on
Cable as a matter of fact
and Adam said that his residuals for
Adam ruins everything and this was
everyone who worked on the production
was twenty thousand dollars now it seems
like a lot
to most people but this is a residual
that is supposed to get these writers
and actors through a period where they
wouldn't have work because they do work
and then they don't do work and then
they go do work and then they don't do
work it's not like a job where you go
every single week every single day and
set time
it's from job to job to job it's each
project a project a project that's how
they make their living
and his residual was twenty thousand
dollars
it's a pretty good residual
his Netflix show that he did under the
Obama production company and Netflix
Netflix paid him 500
not 500 000 not five thousand not fifty
thousand five hundred dollars as a
residual
that's the difference between what was
with a very small cable network and
Netflix
that's what these writers and these
these actors are asking for
is that they get paid and Adam made a
good point on that on that show he said
it wasn't just me that received the
residual all the people who worked on
the production the writers
received the people that are unnamed are
unfaced in the production received the
twenty thousand dollar residual
so the people who rely on that money
are fighting for their right to have
that money not necessarily the Brad
Pitt's and the Leonardo DiCaprio's their
deals are fine
their deals are are amongst the best
but the big actors the big money makers
that you know as rich
Hollywood Elites
are the ones standing with the people
who need to make the deal so that they
can survive their way of life
track [__] rocket science
and Leslie Jones uh spells it out in a
video I think I think I'm gonna show
that today also today we have our great
guest Jess Piper an audience favorite
I'm excited to have Jess back on the
show
I was just reading an article in the
Missouri independent.com you know Jess
does a lot of work here in Missouri my
home state of Missouri and she does work
all around to get Grassroots
um Democrats on ballots in these
uncontested races in these states
for the state representative seats these
State Senate seats because a lot of them
go uncontested and that's why
Republicans run away and have majority
super majority sometimes in these states
is because they just go uncontested
there's no Democrat that is running so
she's working hard
and she calls out the right wing
so of course she's near and dear to my
heart for that but I was reading an
article in the Missouri independent
where the state of Missouri and I'm
going to ask Jess about this we're going
to talk about the ndaa and about women
Banning Women's Health Care in certain
states where you have to cross state
lines and the Republicans think that
that's just dandy that's just dandy that
they could go across state lines matter
of fact they think it's so Dandy they'll
pass laws outlawing it
and then they'll say well they can just
cross state lines yeah but Mr Mr
politician who doesn't have a uterus
don't you know it's illegal you pass the
law Republicans passed a law to make it
illegal to cross state lines oh well
that doesn't matter
get over it
women don't deserve health care so
that's how they feel that's how that's
what they're saying out loud I'm finally
glad that the that the Republican Party
the America real America First Nazi
party is saying quiet Parts out loud we
should be excited about this you should
heard the quiet Parts out loud this this
weekend at turning points USA and I'll
get to that in a second
we're gonna watch clips from that too
but this Missouri uh independent article
missouriindependent.com
the Missouri Republicans really don't
want to participate in a food program
that allows for a hundred and twenty
dollars per child a month who qualifies
for the uh for free and reduced lunch
any any child that qualifies for free
and reduced lunch gets Federal funding
this is not State funding this is
federal funding they just have to
administrate it
so the Missouri
in Boston Smalls pointed it out to me on
Twitter and I'll show you that too
Missouri Missouri Republicans are like
save the children we need to have we
need to pass trans and bathroom bills
and trans athlete bills because the
children but they don't want to feed
children they don't give a [__] about
children let's be clear about that so
I'm gonna ask Jess Piper about this back
to the turning points USA thing though
oh my God the Nazi rally this weekend
you talk about quiet part out loud you
talk about great ads that Democrats can
make off this holy [__] Marjorie Taylor
green basically does a full on sale of
why you should vote for Joe Biden it's
incredible
they don't they don't even hear
themselves anymore I don't even I don't
even know if they try this stuff out
I mean I mean I think they used to be
like should we say that let's go talking
in the mirror let's talk it out of it
and see if that's a good
narrative if we want to [__] all over
Medicare and Social Security if we want
to make sure that Americans know that we
hate it and we'll take it away from them
maybe maybe we should work that out a
bit nope nope [__] no they just full on
balls deep go in for it
they go for it I'm like yeah let's [__]
let's take it away let's demonize it
let's say that we shouldn't even had it
in the first place [__] them
I again I know I know a lot of people
out there are getting super frustrated
and the reason why is because we're
edging up to the end of July beginning
of August uh funny Willis is going to be
uh probably presenting charges not just
for Trump but his allies in his in his
coup attempt uh to try to overturn to
try to sway the Georgia election and
steal the Georgia election away from Joe
Biden
the rightful winner
and I know people are getting frustrated
right and I and I unders I understand
the frustration right
of Republicans being held accountable I
mean [__] Steve Bannon was on stage this
weekend yelling and screaming that
[__] is it got Trader written
all over him he looked pregnant by the
way [__] weird I don't know if that
guy's drink is drinking straight whiskey
or just pumping it into his veins
he looks like he's got a a bad liver
problem if you want to know the truth he
looked pregnant as [__] that ain't fat I
mean he's he's tubby but that ain't fat
that's a health issue when you got a
pregnant belly like that holy [__] and
these people out there talking about
gender reconfirming surgery hey Steve
looks like you need to lay off the sauce
because it looks like you're
transitioning to a pregnant man it just
that's what it looks like to me what do
you want from me I don't decide these
things I just show them to you I'll show
it to you
but a lot of people are getting
frustrated with the timing that is
happening also the Canon decision on
whether she's going to punt the trial
she will
folks I I don't know I don't know how
else to tell you this
and I know some people are frustrated
with me attacking legal analyst
apparently
I'm going to attack anyone who [__]
lies to you who is trying to give you
hope even even if they're lying to give
you hope
there's no one there's no reason to feed
you full lines of [__] there's just
not there's not
and there's Talking Heads on and on on
cable news cable news okay
and legal analyst on cable news who
continue to try to get paint some furry
picture that Jack Smith and the doj and
Merritt Garland Are Gonna Save Our
democracy that is not their job
okay learn what their job is their job
is to prosecute criminals
all right their job is not to to
interfere in democracy that's our job
that's our job is democracy
their job is to do the will of the
people we the people and we say hey
there's crime go prosecute it now is
there is there problems with the justice
system of course there is of course
there's a two-tier justice system why do
you think it's been taken so long for
Trump to be prosecuted for something
because there is a two-tier justice
system in this country and the reason
why Maga is so pissed off about the
two-tier justice system is because
Trump's tier is not going to protect him
and his allies anymore
and it seems that Jack Smith and other
prosecutors are going to make sure that
happens it's gonna take a bit though
folks it's gonna take a little bit
you can't prosecute these types of
crimes just in a day
you have to be patient the work of
democracy is not the Department of
Justice
it's not the the the work of democracy
is not the it's not the job of Jack
Smith or Merrick Garland
they are prosecutors they prosecute
crimes that is their job our job our job
as the pro-democracy Coalition is to
engage in our democracy and do the work
of our Democratic constitutional
republic
and elect leaders that will represent us
in a way
that is serious about policy serious
about our democracy that's the whole
point
that's the whole point
not not not to rely on on a Department
of Justice to save our democracy that
it's not their job
it's not and if you think it's their job
you need to do a little bit more
thinking
a little bit more thinking and if you're
relying on them if you're cheering for
them great
but if your only hope is pinned
to Donald Trump being prosecuted and
going to trial and being put in a prison
cell you're mistaken
folks they will nominate him even if
he's in a prison cell and they can
there's nothing that doesn't say he
can't be nominated if he's sitting in a
jail cell somewhere you know that right
there is nothing stopping him
even if he is jailed there is nothing
stopping him from being the nominee you
know that right
so we are Trump Trump's jury and I'll
say it again and again and over and over
and over again we are Trump's jury so
don't be frustrated
don't be frustrated with outcomes that
you can't control do what you can
control what you can do is you can
control your engagement in your
democracy that's what you can control
you can control that you can point your
strategic outrage in a way that advances
a narrative and messaging to make sure
that the country knows that next
November to vote for democracy not
autocracy
and vote against Trump
that is the turnout that is the page
Turner
I know we I know you want me to get you
all hyped up about Joe Biden how excited
you should be listen I think he is one
of the most effective presidents in our
modern history I actually believe that
history will tell a better story of Joe
Biden than I could ever ever give you in
a two-hour show here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
but that's not the danger
the danger is not how well Joe Biden
will do or won't do or how well he's
done or hasn't done the danger is the
alternative
to what serious policy makers who
believe in democracy are doing
that is the danger
that is what could unify our democracy
to save it not relying on Jack Smith
we can't rely on one man it's just not
possible Jack Smith Merrick Garland or
Joe Biden we cannot rely on them
democracy is the work of the people
It Is Us
it is we
who are the ones who can save our
country our nation
from the scourge of fascism
the authoritarian authoritarian dumb
bucks knocking at our door because boy
are they knocking I don't know if you
saw the turning points USA oh my God
baby oh man
who man they love them cinematocracy
they loves them some theocracy oh man
they really want to tell you and get
your religion all up in that all up in
your China they do I'm telling you and
they are cyber focused on genitalia and
cocaine they can't get their minds off
cocaine fuel text orgies it seems to me
I don't know they keep talking about
cocaine and genitalia that's all they
talk about
foreign
USA and I'm going to show you a hey I
showed it last night on the patreon
Sunday rant
a clip of Assa Hutchinson the former uh
governor of Arkansas
being booed basically and then Trump's
name being chanted while he was speaking
it caused him he had the microphone and
he still couldn't speak over them
and I believe it's more evidence of what
I've been saying since the end of
December beginning of January which is
that Trump will be the nominee you
cannot stop it
not DeSantis
not Chris Christie not Nikki Haley no
one is going to stop him from being the
nominee
I don't care which who's [__] backing
them I don't care how much money is
backing them they're not going to stop
him from being the nominee
and if you think that you are you don't
understand how Cults work
and that leads me to the No Labels
lead-in
No Labels is trying hard to make sure
that if Trump is the nominee that they
make sure to Edge out some of Joe
Biden's vote here's the thing the reason
why Democrats and Joe Biden want Donald
Trump to be the nominee because they
really truly do I'll tell you the truth
they might not tell you on MSNBC or
wherever but here I will tell you the
truth the Democrats want Trump
the reason why is because they know
where to beat him
they know where to beat him they know
where Joe Biden's votes are to win
they have an exact [__] map folks
it's not rocket science
Joe Biden beat Donald Trump handily
in the 2020 election
not only that they are counting on
demographics to sway towards Joe Biden
and as the Republican party and and
Grandpa poopy pants to Cheeto dust cue
and honor become more more [__] crazy
crazier than they could ever become more
of a lunatic
they know they're going to Edge those
Suburban moderate independent votes
quote moderate independent they're
actually they're liberals they're
socialists they just don't know it
they are you can hate me all you want
they truly are they just don't know they
are
but they know they're going to win those
votes
they know they can win and sway those
votes towards Biden
that's why Democrats want Trump they
know where they can win
they know it
so have no fear but we must not stop
engaging because today when I have Jess
Piper on I'm going to ask her a specific
question because I and I think I ask her
this each time she's on and I want to
see if her answer changes at all
because the top of the ballot is very
important for turnout it's very
important we get the top of the ballot
to cause turnout against trumpism
because what we can do in the politics
of it when you politicize things like we
do here on the Tony Michaels podcast
that's right I said it we politicize
things I'm not scared
of saying that's what we do we are
trying to create a national narrative
that is going to push this country
towards democracy not autocracy we're
going to use our strategic outrage to
engage in our democracy to make sure of
it
so we will politicize every single issue
and we will message them in a way to
politicize the issue to get that turnout
against American fascism which is known
as trumpism
that is what we can do and if we do that
we can win down ballot races we can win
the the United States House of
Representatives back we can make Hakeem
Jeffries
the first black speaker of the house
probably the longest serving speaker of
the house if you want to know the honest
truth
as effective as the king Jeffries is and
as well as he messages if he becomes the
speaker of the house it is likely if we
keep our messaging up and we keep
engaging in our democracy he will be the
speaker of the house for a long time
also making gains in the Senate is
crucial
to this country and down ballot races
there's going to be race here in
Missouri and race around several other
states for those United States Senate
seats how much would you love to hear
that Josh Hawley lost his Senate race as
an incumbent
who baby that would be fantastic
but more importantly these State races
we see more and more these states using
their super majority of [__] Nazis
Republican Nazis inside their state
Chambers
stripping away people's rights
that's what they want to do is to
oppress your rights and the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
it is not Liberty
so the question is what will you do
will you engage in your democracy or
will you sit back and decide that you
know what this No Label thing Donald
Trump being the nominee I'm just gonna
let Jack Smith handle that
I'm just going to let the department of
just Justice save me and save my country
my way of life I'll just rely on them
what are you gonna do is it going to be
you or is it going to be them I think it
should be you and I think you should
join me every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube subscribe
hit the like button now if you haven't
hit the like button go ahead and hit the
like button hit the like button
don't forget it's right it's right it's
someone right in here
oh well
some people are on Facebook and the like
button's in a different spot I'm not
really sure where it's at on Facebook
but follow us at the Tony Michaels you
can watch it for free there it's free 99
this show is free 99 on Facebook as well
and I want to thank all the viewers on
Twitch there is a lively chat that
happens over on Twitch
and you can give us monetary support for
free that's right you can give us
monetary support for free on Twitch you
just go to twitch.tv slash D Tony
Michaels and you subscribe with your
Amazon Prime account did you know that
if you have an Amazon Prime account you
can actually link it to your Twitch
account
and you get one free subscription with
Amazon gaming it's incredible now we
only get a couple bucks of the five
dollars but it's free for you if you're
an Amazon Prime member so go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com it's the fourth link down
just push the button it'll give you
directions on how to link your Amazon
Prime account and your Twitch account
it's fantastic also the mighty librarian
or Greek moderator put the directions on
how to resubscribe every single month
because you do have to resubscribe every
single month and animal mother 2021 just
re-subscribed here and gave a message
said [__] them Tony so thank you thank
you animal mother 2021 for resubscribing
this month for the second month in a row
everyone go over to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels tie your Amazon account to that
give us a little bit of Monastery
monetary support without costing you a
single extra nickel
oh man I'm super excited about my guest
it's been several weeks since she's been
on and there's been a lot of news since
and I really want to ask her about this
article um in the Missouri independent
where I know we're going to talk about
the in the AAA we're going to talk about
the state these states trying to ban
Women's Health Care that's how we should
be saying it ban women they're banning
Women's Health Care
they're banning women's right to their
health care into their decisions of
their health care but this Missouri
independent article I think is very very
interesting uh the federal funding of
120 worth of benefits to each eligible
child
that gets free introduced lunch Missouri
is like no [__] you we don't like kids
you know that all that saved the kids
thing that us Republicans talk about
every day we don't really believe it
it's all [__] so we're going to talk
about that with Jess Piper and much more
right after this don't go anywhere don't
go anywhere just just Pipers next stay
right there
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
thank you jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels podcast
I think we're gonna have to add Barbie
to the boycott binder why are they so
mad about Barbie I don't understand
something about Chinese propaganders
them from Ted Cruz and his wife no one
in our house to watch Barbie
listen they have daughters their [__]
daughters played with Barbies they're so
full of [__] I can smell them from here
I'm in Missouri they're in Texas
speaking of Missouri I have a great
great person who is doing a lot of hard
work in my state of Missouri and other
states but Missouri specifically she's
going around the state finding these
candidates to contest these Republicans
and these State races which is so
important and I I'm glad to have her
back on the show my friend Jess Piper
Jess I'm so glad to have you back how
are you my friend I'm doing great how
are you I'm fantastic I'm fantastic I'm
I'm super happy that you're back and I'm
glad that we're going to talk about ndaa
today but the first thing I want to go
through is an article that I have up
here it's the Missouri independent
um it says Missouri has declined to uh
decided excuse me to turn down millions
in federal food aid for low-income
children now you know for the people who
say they really like children and like
that's their number one focus and
they're hyper focused on saving the
children from the demon Democrats why
wouldn't they want to feed children this
doesn't seem to compute with me
um it's because they don't they don't
care about the poor children oh oh oh
okay okay so when they say save the
children they mean save the rich white
children is that what they is that what
they mean actually what they mean is a
racist dog whistle but you know that's a
really long story all right right right
they don't care about saving the
children they're all about you know
marrying them off um when they're old
enough to or not quite old enough to
procreate
um they don't care I there was uh sin
well he's running for Senate his name is
representative Doug Richie I think he's
close to Lee's Summit uh yesterday was
tweeting about the fact that he talked
to superintendents of schools who wanted
to Institute a universal free lunch plan
and he was like why because you want
your kids to have free lunch you make
six figures a year and the
superintendents were like dude no
there's lots of poor kids in our
district we're just trying to get them
lunch
is this it right here see I'm fast I'm
fast I've got it yeah that's him and now
he is a forced birther and so the weird
thing about him is that he he doesn't
want poor children to have access to
free lunch but he does want to force
them to carry the pregnancy of a rape or
incest you know um their Uncle
um has molested them and now they're
forced to carry this pregnancy thanks to
Doug
feels like Doug we need to check his
electronic devices I don't know I'm just
saying I I mean I I don't know why I get
that sense but maybe maybe that's just
it here's what you actually said about
it I saw your Tweet earlier that's why I
was so quick on it uh you said uh here
here it is you said this man is running
for state senate in Missouri his divorce
birth or his questions the motivation
superintendent's trying to get free
lunches for poor children while knowing
knowing he would force these poor hungry
children to deliver the pregnancy of a
rape there is no bottom there isn't a
bottom for Republicans I watched a clip
of a and I think you posted it and I
played it yesterday on my patreon on my
Sunday rant uh for patreon for my
patreon
um and here's the thing this guy in Iowa
he
he seems to believe that um people
choose when they have sex and also he
seems to think that when you're pregnant
it has nothing to do with Reproductive
Rights I don't how and how in the world
is this even possible is it because he's
a Republican or is it because he's a man
I'm trying to decide which it is but
it's you know it's misogyny it's it's
thinking that you know they know better
I see tweets all the time um and and
when I talk to lawmakers face to face
this is what they say Eric Burleson was
just talking about this the other day
he's a congressman from Missouri they're
talking about the fact that there's a
huge drought and that farmers know that
their cows need water Farmers know best
he kept saying get bureaucracy the
bureaucrats out of farming because
Farmers know best about their cows and I
was like you won't even get the
bureaucrats out of our health care if
anyone knows about a woman's body it's
the woman who owns the body but they're
so disconnected from reality they're so
into this Christian nationalism that
they'll talk about Farmers knowing
what's best for cows but women don't
know what's best for their own bodies
because basically we are Channel we are
cows to them we are that sort of
property that he's talking about they
don't see a disconnect in it because
that's the way they feel
I I well here let me play this clip here
I've got it here this is the and I
forget this guy's name here I think it's
Sherman of Iowa now we know Iowa last
week
um you know Kim Reynolds that scumbag of
a governor up there Kim right yes um Kim
Reynolds signed uh to ban women's health
care and that's the way we need to be
saying it yeah I know I know the
abortion word is a real cool buzzword
but really this is about women's health
care this is not about specific
specific uh uh procedures this is about
women's health care and then pushing
back the rights of women having the
ability to choose what their health care
is going to be between them and their
doctor but listen to this scumbag talk
about sex and pregnancy and I I don't
know I I just it's hard to understand
but let's see if we can make heads and
tails of what the what the bonehead is
saying here I think I stand here today
in favor
uh and and proclaiming that everyone is
free not to have sex oh geez
if they're not prepared to have a baby
they shouldn't have sex now I'm just
going down a limb here and Jess and I'm
going to say that this guy doesn't have
the option to have
what he's talking about much I'm just
maybe he doesn't have the opportunity to
do things much that's why he thinks that
you know other people don't I don't know
it just it seems
that's what he thinks he has freedom to
have sex anytime he wants
oh oh oh there's the misogyny that's
what you're talking about yeah because
we are just vessels waiting to be filled
with a pregnancy and to deliver because
that is what they think uh the point of
a woman is and that's the point of our
life is to procreate as often as
possible women should not be having sex
for recreation or fun and I guarantee
you ain't nobody having sex for fun with
that man nobody right nobody well I mean
if you heard the words that came out of
his mouth fun is nowhere near this guy
nothing is wrong I talked about this and
I said you know women have the right to
have sex for other reasons than
reproduction we have that right and I
mean the folks and the comments lost
their ever loving minds they were insane
and I was like this is weird this is the
hill you're gonna die on that women
should only have sex to to reproduce
maybe they should do these humans do
these humans do these humans not know
that sex is fun do they not know that
they don't they're conservatives I I
guess I guess not I guess not it's um
it's damage that has been done to them
maybe but let's listen to the damage
that this guy is doing in the um in Iowa
there let's listen
if they're that concerned about it
I will stand for everyone's right to
practice abstinence oh geez abortion has
little if anything to do with
Reproductive Rights it's after it has
everything to do with it how how and you
know that's why that's why I keep
telling the audience stop saying the
word abortion it's Way Beyond abortion
at this point these people are not
they're using that word and they're
using those procedures as a way to ban
Women's Health Care they're banning
women's rights to Health Care state
after state after State and this is what
I was saying in the lead-up that it's so
important because the top of the ballot
race is going to get us turnout right if
Trump does end up being the nominee if
we can get an anti-trump turnout it is
going to be a massive turnout just like
it was in 2020 I believe but how do we
because I know this is what you're
working on the project you're working on
how do we take that top of the ballot
turnout for the presidential race the
United States Senate that United States
House of Representatives and how do we
get it in places like Iowa in Missouri
to make sure that this [__] is not
happening where they're banning people's
rights women trans people trans children
the lgbtq community how do we get it
from the turnout from the top of the
ballot all the way to the down ballot
because I know that's what you're
focused on it is and it actually works
from the bottom up okay wearing a
presidential election we may have more
people but
um I just wrote a piece for the Kansas
City Star that they published yesterday
in the Sunday edition which was great
and it talks about the fact that when I
was knocking doors people would say yeah
well Joe Biden or Trump or whatever and
I'm like friend he has nothing to do
with your roads or your health care or
your schools or your hospitals nothing
other than sending money for
infrastructure right I mean all this
money that we got to expand I-70 where
do you think that came from that came
from the federal government right you
mean the white you mean the one that
Parsons said he didn't want but now he
likes right those things my um my
Senator or my congressman his name Sam
Graves he's been in there for 20 22
years he had the audacity to applaud
what's going on in the city just south
of me called Maryville we're getting an
expansion of the road so we can actually
like have turn signals and you know
lights and he said Thanks To Us whoa
whoa you mean uh traffic lights exist
they exist it's 2023 Jess you're you're
really hopping up on technology there
that's crazy in my actual town we don't
have a stoplight but that's beyond the
point
um but he was congratulating those who
voted for it guess who didn't vote for
that in his own District Sam Graves he
turned away that money but he's talking
about what a good thing it is so we need
to to stop when we're talking to our
neighbors and catch them and say did you
see what Sam grave said about Maryville
did you see how he was talking about our
turning you know Lanes now you know he
turned down that money and we beat it
over and over and over and over again
because everything that matters to us in
this state comes from our state reps and
our state senators the feds just send us
money that's it there is no reason to
pay attention at most points because
every thing that is Unholy and awful in
our lives is happening at the state
level and so it's getting people to
focus on that and we as Democrats and I
say this every time I'm on your show but
we as Democrats threw our hands up and
walked away from 40 of the seats in
Missouri
66 reps went to Jeff City without even a
job interview they didn't campaign they
didn't talk to voters they didn't do
anything and they are down there making
extremist laws with no no one contesting
them 2.5 million missourians had no
choice so when people say to me as a
rural person you guys vote against your
self-interest this is what I say to them
I don't have a way to vote in my
self-interest there is no one to vote
for we don't have candidates on the
ballot and that's what I'm trying to
impress on people it's bottom up you
have to pay attention to what's
happening in your local races because
Joe Biden or Trump I mean not much is
going to impact us right Trump had some
awful policies during his period did it
impact a whole lot of people in
Northwest Missouri that much
not that much but our our state reps
wrote abortion bans they banned books
they banned curriculum do you know there
is a hospital in Cameron Missouri a
rural town that they just quit having
deliveries there there are no OBS
anymore in that town and they are
sending pregnant sometimes sick
sometimes septic women 90 miles south to
Kansas City to deliver and this is what
we talk about when it impacts Women's
Health Care these women want to be
pregnant they want to have babies and
there are terrible outcomes for women
who cannot access health care and why
are OBS leaving because of the abortion
ban because they are scared for their
licenses if they have to perform an
abortion on someone who is miscarried or
whose baby is dying and the woman is
septic and this is what this is why it's
so important that you're talking about
health care because that's what it is
you know that you make a good point
there and the cruelty is the point right
and a lot of people would think why are
Republicans setting policies that affect
their constituents so much and a lot of
times I say it's because they can go
well thanks Joe Biden thanks Joe Biden
this rural hospitals thanks Obamacare
this rural hospital is closing we see
that in Tennessee now and they do this
over and over and over and they've been
doing this with the ndaa we know there's
been a big fight over the ndaa because
Republicans again are just vile pieces
of sludge but this is going into not
just the federal level right it's going
into state laws where States the states
have banned the ability for women to
cross a state line to receive Health
Care like you said that from Cameron
they go 90 miles south in the state but
what if they're somewhere in the state
that they have to cross a state line or
maybe there isn't a procedure that of
Health Care that that woman that woman
can choose and she has to cross the
state line they've been trying to make
it illegal and these these these United
States reps when they're talking about
this stuff
um it's kind of it's really
um it's really scummy of course they're
Republicans so it is but this is
represented McCall of Texas talking
about this and talking about women
crossing state lines now I'm going to
give you a caveat because I'm not a real
fan of Margaret men and I'm just not and
I think she um is doing not she's doing
a disservice to us as a country and and
the media by not pressuring him here
more she kind of lets him get away with
it I think some people think she didn't
let him get away with but she totally
does she should press him and and to me
politicians I don't care who they are
especially Republicans though but I
don't care who they are they're supposed
to be tough they they run they're a
public life they're in a they're in a
public office they're supposed to be
tough they can handle tough questions
and I just don't think she gets at the
tough questions here but let's listen
how they're framing the issue of women's
health care and crossing state lines
because you did vote to eliminate the
diversity offices at the Pentagon to
deny transgender troops coverage for
hormone therapy for this restriction on
funding for people to get
um Reproductive Services including
fertility treatments and abortions to
travel
none of that you think ends up well
because that goes against none of those
things will get done well it goes
against since 1980 we haven't funded
anything that goes towards taxpayer you
know abortions I think some of the
policies on a culture that the that the
defense department has instituted has
caused problems within our own military
recruitment is an all-time low now after
Afghanistan and then to watch these
videos that these these uh trained you
know say seals have to watch uh you know
injecting their own social moral
policies let's make it about readiness
in our ability to fight well yeah and
that's why uh the defense secretary said
what one in five troops are now female
and that what he put this policy in to
be able to do is for them to travel to
get things that aren't covered
in the States they're living so should
shouldn't all troops regardless of where
they're stationed get the same treatment
like why penalize them for living in
Texas they're free to travel to another
state uh to have they'd be penalized
they have to change yeah proportion just
not taxpayer expense
they'd have to take the time off and and
the like and so that would impact their
ability to do their jobs arguably right
if they have to to go only but anyway I
want to also ask so there it is and I
again I think she lets him get away with
it but the idea is that they're saying
oh well when when we banned it in States
Our intention wasn't to make sure that
the the National Defense authorization
act they can travel now they can travel
out of Texas we made it illegal here but
that's tough [__] that's just tough [__]
if you're going to be stationed in Texas
I mean you weren't Cho you didn't choose
to be stationed in Texas it seems like
the dod chose for you to be stationed in
Texas now you're a military wife and I
know this ndaa and some of this uh
commentary on this is probably uh really
close and near and dear to your heart
and and you've experienced some of this
stuff so tell us tell us what you make
of McCall and then I'm gonna go to a
clip of Josh Hawley talking about the
same thing well I have to correct you
because I'm a military daughter military
Mom oh there you go there you go oh
there you go I do understand and this is
um very problematic but I'm telling you
that this is exactly what women in red
states have
um been under for years there there's no
access to abortion in Northwest Missouri
and there hasn't been for decades if a
woman needed an abortion in this part of
the state she would need to leave the
state she would need to go to to
um you know Omaha or somewhere like that
because Des Moines has already passed
right an abortion ban St Louis is five
and a half hours away from us they
there's also been bills in Missouri that
have been written by one was by Mary
Elizabeth Coleman to restrict the travel
of pregnant people in this state to
actually Place bounties on women who
have left the state now it didn't get a
hearing but if you think it's not going
to come up again you're crazy this is
exactly what they're wanting to do and I
know people talk about you know the you
know the handmaid's tale all the time
but it's really truly
um this dystopian future where women can
make no decisions about their own body
and they can't get a way to make any
decisions these women in the military
you're right did not choose where they
are going and so this Senator is saying
well they can leave if they want to how
would they how do you just walk away
from your position you have to leave I
mean if you work if you work at Dollar
General and you need an abortion you
know you can leave and just say well I'm
I'm taking Tuesday Wednesday off as
military personnel that's not how it
works a woman can't just say I'll be
back in five days don't ask any
questions that's not how it works you
don't know what they're doing you know
it's it's almost it's almost like like
you said they know that but here's the
thing about that as well is that
um when you actually have to take leave
to go out of state that's actually a
benefit that's given to you by the
federal government whether it's paid or
unpaid it's a paid benefit which is
compensation of of your or benefits
package when you're in the military
which is federal aid and when you Force
and and I can see them doing this inside
state laws I really can see them saying
hey you can't you can't take unpaid lead
that's compensation from the federal
government you can't take unpaid leave
and go out of state because that's
compensation you're using Federal
benefits to go get your health care
services which is against the law here
in Texas and we will penalize you for it
or we will put a bounty on you or
whatever you can't leave the state
because those or whether it's paid or
unpaid is benefits that's given by DOD
to those soldiers and that's and and
that's the [__] thin line that they
always cross now I said I had a clip
from Josh Hawley and I and you can see
my mistake here this is the senator from
your original State Arkansas you know
Josh Hawley Tom Cotton potato right one
guy right right I mean how are all these
how are all these fascists just a
complete cookie cutter right it seems
weird it seems weird all you need is to
be thin wear skinny jeans graduate from
Yale and tell everybody else what to do
with their own goddamn business that's
all they need to do right and tell you
and tell tell them how manly you are
when you clearly you clearly don't know
what being a man is about well here's
here's the Arkansas Senator Tom Cotton
telling telling people who are women
what he thinks who is not a woman what
to do again the arm the military should
not be paying for abortion tourism so
what should women who are in uniform in
a place where they cannot access
abortion because they are there on
orders what should they do
well if they want to take that step they
have 30 days of annual leave it
shouldn't be taxpayer fines giving them
three weeks of paid uncharged leave and
then also paying for travel and lodging
and meals something that we don't even
give our troops when they have a parent
die or a sibling die or a beloved
grandparent die okay just I want to ask
you a question
when a loved one dies is that health
care because it seems like it might be I
mean I don't know how Tom Cotton is
squaring someone dying as health care
but you know I maybe I'm wrong I could
be completely wrong there one thing he
really pointed to the fact that the
military does a horrible job of giving
people bereavement right that's what I
found out there but also no one is
asking for you to get to pay for a hotel
room to get to have an abortion nobody's
paying for asking you to pay for travel
women are asking for the leave that they
need to go and get the health care that
they need right the Hyde Amendment Pro
you know it's been in effect for decades
we can't not use funds federal funds to
pay for abortion right but these women
the fact is that these women are chained
to where they are and they cannot leave
so he's saying abortion terrorism this
is stupid as [__] I have ever heard in
my life
he should have an abortion and then tell
me what it feels like to be a tourist in
an abortion clinic right it ain't fun
Tom that is the most moronic [__] I've
ever heard in my life but besides that
these women aren't asking for travel
benefits or hotel benefits they're
asking to cross state lines to get the
care they need but this goes back to the
states right and this goes back to those
down about races because what Tom Cotton
is really saying is hey we passed laws
to where you have to go to a different
state we did that so that you as a woman
have to go to a different state to
receive your health care and nana boo
boo stick your head and do to you if you
can't do it fine whatever we don't care
because we really don't want you to get
the health care that you that you have
the right to anyways so haha and and
that's really at the heart of this is
because if we weren't having these
fascist red States passing and banning
Women's Health Care like Iowa's done
like Missouri's tried to do like Texas
has done these women would be able to
receive Health Care in their home States
in their communities if they would
Embrace I don't know maybe they would
Embrace embrace the ACA they would
Embrace rural hospitals they would make
sure that they did Medicaid expansion to
make sure that rural hospitals had the
funding to stay open maybe they would
have these hospitals maybe they had
these facilities in these OB gyns in
their communities where women wouldn't
even have to think about traveling out
of state it just seems like they did
something to cause a problem and now
they're blaming the problem that they
caused as as why they can't do anything
for Women's Health Care and why they
just have to ban it all together it's
almost like that Tony you hit on their
entire strategy create a problem when
there is in is none and then try to to
fix it but here's the thing they want to
be pro-life you know what you could do
you could have comprehensive sex ed so
that people didn't get pregnant when
they didn't want to you could have free
birth control so people don't get
pregnant if they don't want to you can
have access to
um affordable affordable housing and to
living wages and making sure that
everyone has health insurance and you
can make sure if people did want to have
a baby that they have affordable child
care that they have fully funded schools
all of these things reduce pregnancies
accidental pregnancies that these people
want to reduce right they claim that
they're pro-life and they don't want
these pregnancies to happen but they rip
away all of the programs that we need to
keep these pregnancies from happen
nobody wants an abortion nobody says my
my goal in life is to terminate a
pregnancy it's uncomfortable it's
expensive and sometimes it it does weigh
on some women's Minds right they women
in general do not want to have abortions
but this is part of the health care that
we need because things happen but we can
reduce pregnancies by using Common Sense
approaches that the Republicans oppose
at every single juncture
you know like the great George Carlin
once said they're not pro-life they're
anti-woman yeah they're not pro-life
they're anti-woman period And I I
believe that is true and I believe that
is true about this this little um
fascist in a skin suit just like the
other one we were talking about Josh
Hawley I believe the same thing suggests
I'm I'm so excited you came back and I'm
so excited that I got a chance to ask
you about all these topics because I
isn't a woman so I try to be an ally but
I'm so glad to have you here to speak on
these issues so that the audience gets a
sense of what others are talking about
in the space so tell us how does the
audience find you I know you have a new
threads account I follow you over there
too I'm trying to do both it's it's a
lot to manage to do both but I'm
following over there too but you have a
threads account tell everyone I know the
moderators we've got the link tree your
link tree down in the description below
but tell us where they find you and tell
us what they can do because that's the
most important part not just follow Jess
but what they can do you what people can
do to engage in their democracy not just
online but in real life and online what
can they do tell us yes if you want to
be involved the easy way you can donate
to Blue Missouri which is the the
organization I'm working with we fund
down ballot candidates we're not
grifters we don't take or skim any money
off of it what you give to candidates
100 goes to candidates we work off the
tip function so don't give us a tip if
you don't want to but the whole goal is
to fund down ballot candidates that will
make a difference in our state other
than that you can find me at Jess Piper
for Missouri or Piper for Missouri on
Instagram and Facebook and threads at
justpipermo on Tick Tock I have a weekly
podcast called the dirt road Democrat
where I talk to folks about issues that
you know rule that impact rural
communities
um but the last thing I want to tell
your audience is to have hope you know
we get on and we talk a lot about what's
going wrong because we have to point our
finger at who is causing the problem but
there is hope right um the the Young
Folks are coming out to vote in droves
they're going to be the largest SEC
segment of the voting population very
soon they are not impressed with
Republicans they will not vote for
Republicans so we keep moving forward at
my final piece of advice is pay
attention to your local politics State
politics those are most impactful to
your life and I appreciate you thank you
so much oh I I hope you can come back to
join us soon everyone you can see the
link tree there on on the screen uh
linktree Slash Jess Piper go visit all
her links follow her everywhere even on
threads even on the new the new
anti-twitter threads go over there I
again I've been trying to do back and
forth I'm trying it I'm trying to see I
think threads is is going to be a good
thing eventually but it's going to take
it's going to take a little bit Jess
thanks for joining us everyone stick
around we'll be right back for more good
to see you my friend we'll talk to you
very soon Instagram we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
description below follow on Facebook
follow her on Twitter follow her on
threads anywhere you can go she also has
a podcast
um and you can find those episodes and
she talks more and more about the state
races so I try to bring guests that give
you uh different ways to engage in your
democracy we have Rachel Dr Rachel
bittickoff are on she's going to go
after the federal level right she's
gonna hit him where it hurts as she says
in her new book
another way you can order that you can
pre-order that a lot of people have
messaged me that they're pre-ordering
Doc's book it's a great idea by the way
to get pre-ordered that way you get
first dibs of it but you should follow
and look and and look at the tweets of
people like Jess Piper who are really
doing the work in these states because I
know Jess talked about Missouri but it
can happen in your state too you can do
the work in your state there are people
doing work in those States and to follow
to follow those people and to make
inroads in some of these uncontested
races where Republicans just run away
with it and it's not it's not a thing
that we should be allowing we should
give the the choice
of those constituents to choose between
a fascist a Republican or someone who is
serious about policy serious about their
constituents and serious about their
Community which more than likely is a
Democrat
so engage in your democracy do that
looks like we have a birthday in the
chat I'm gonna I'm gonna stop we got a
birthday uh Happy Birthday Nadine I
believe
or Nanette excuse me Nanette that's what
it is
happy birthday to you uh we're gonna
have Gabe Sanchez joining us here in
just a minute
that's right Gabe Sanchez is back
Gabe Sanchez is back oh yeah that's
right Marky points out the uh the
podcast for Jess is dirt road Democrat
podcast so check out the dirt road
Democrat podcast from Jess Piper you're
going to get a lot of ideas now she
talks a lot about Missouri but she's
going to give you a lot of ideas as you
listen to her talk and as you read her
tweets and you see how she attacks some
of these State uh these State uh uh
representatives and state senators are
people running for state senator or
state representative when she attacks
them she can get she can get you in the
right position to do the same thing in
your state
um and a lot a lot of people don't know
but the state representatives especially
these Republicans they really try to
take the model like Lauren bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green where they're
trying to just be just absolute
[__] on social media like just
total [__] like it's all [__]
Nazi cosplay on social media right
they're not really serious people and
when you find them it's really easy to
go in and just start just lay laying it
on to them
and and making sure that they get good
pushback because they're not going to
get good pushback in the media
um actually this this interview that I
show with Tom Cotton with Jess the Fox
News host and I don't know her name here
uh the Fox News host here gave uh as
Shannon bream is that her name I don't
know I don't know I don't watch Fox News
but if her name is Shannon she gave way
more pushback than Margaret Brennan gave
to uh representative McCall even on Fox
News which is incredible but that's just
the way it goes sometimes hmm
hmm
it's a really strange and weird Okay
um yeah I told you I was going to show
you some clips from the
the Nazi rally at the turning points USA
thing uh this weekend they are getting
more and hey it's wild [__] it's wild
stuff man the quiet part out loud is
just it can't stop
and they're getting more and more Brazen
as it goes along
the one thing though that is hilarious
and it was speaking of Tom gotten in
Arkansas uh the former Governor of
Arkansas Assa Hutchinson do you know
this game you probably wouldn't know him
if you've seen him no one knows who the
[__] this is
but ASA Hutchinson that's right I call
him Assa Hutchinson
um Assa Hutchinson went to the Turning
Point USA event the Nazi rally this
weekend
and he only he created a clip he created
a piece of content for us to know
exactly why Trump will be the nominee
now I've been saying it for a long time
this is the reason why uh and Ron uh
posted this uh and and he even says in
the post yeah it's Ron's post uh he says
this is why DeSantis didn't go to the
event okay which is absolutely true and
the reason why is because this is not
the party of Republicans anymore
this is the party of fascism this is the
party of the real America First Nazis
and Trump
and that is why you'll be the nominee
because it is a cult
they do not care how many felonies he's
charged with they do not care the truth
of it they will listen to the lies they
will believe any lie
that they need to believe so that they
can continue to support his dumb ass now
ASA Hutchinson Assa Hutchinson gets up
on the stage and he begins to speak he
has the microphone it's not like he's
just yelling into the ground he's got
the microphone there's a PA system
but he can't even speak over them listen
to what happens when he starts to speak
listen English essential and
non-essential businesses
and whenever you
you hear what they're chanting they're
chanting Trump
they're chanting Trump as he's talking
and the reason why is because he's
running against Trump
in the primary so he's the enemy if you
catch the drift but the point is this
is that in this small little sect of
turning points USA which is the absolute
loudest and proudest of fascism that
there is now along with the daily wire
but these turning points events who are
funded by the rich Republican donors
probably like Harlan grow
Harlan Hitler as he's known here again
it just proves that they're going to
nominate trump it doesn't matter what
the situation is folks I don't care if
Jack Smith locks him in a jail cell
they're going to nominate him
and the Department of Justice is not
going to save your democracy they're not
they're not
um so that's just more proof and again
I'm going to keep providing it to you as
we go along of proof why he's going to
be the nominee I'm going to be correct
it's it's just how it's going to be
because I understand how Cults work I
understand what the report Republican
party is now they are what they've
always wanted to be
they have become what they've always
wanted to be I watched for years as they
thin veiled their fascism as we're
conservative no you're not uh we're
conservative no you're not you're not
conservative you're fascist you're thin
bailing your Fascism and selling it as
conservatism and low taxes for the rich
because one day you'll be rich
hell and this is what it has devolved
into their nominees standing on stage
talking about laws that don't exist this
is hilarious
this is hilarious a lot of people are
like oh my God this is so dangerous
dangerous for who
for who for Trump this is dangerous for
Trump this guy is charged with 37
felonies under the Espionage Act
the Espionage Act he keeps talking about
the presidential records act and not
only does he keep talking about the
presidential records act he keeps saying
that the law says the opposite of what
it says
[Laughter]
and he thinks that this is a great legal
defense actually I don't believe that he
thinks this is a great legal defense I
believe what he's doing
is he's convincing his supporters and
his followers his sheep Maga that
this defense is the thing that they're
going to use when he's charged and
convicted
because it's all against him and they'll
they'll use anything they can to lock
him up because they're coming after them
or some stupid [__]
but in this clip he is laying out a
legal defense that is very dangerous to
him
to him this is dangerous listen
they indicted
they think of it
you don't have to be a lawyer to
understand those words that's right now
you don't have to be a lawyer to really
understand why they indicted you now
that we know the evidence you really
don't you don't really have to be a
lawyer and just go read the law and
you're like yeah it sounds like you
broke that law dude
dude sounds like you broke a law that
would be a crime and as a matter of fact
37 felonies but you know who's counting
let's continue let's let's listen to the
law that he thinks applies here very as
simple as it gets they indicted me
in other words whatever documents a
president decides to take with him he
has the absolute and unquestioned right
to do so this is a law that was passed
inside uh no that it's not there is not
a law then there is there is not a law
anywhere that says any of that as a
matter of fact they wrote a law so that
didn't happen
like literally the law that he's citing
the presidential record act says the
exact opposite of what he's saying and
actually
says that you can't take the documents
like you can't you don't have they're
not yours they're ours the government
you don't get to do whatever you want
friend just because you were the
president that's not how it works you
you the human held the office the office
is ours all the records and all the
documents that come out of their office
the office that you held is ours that's
what the presidential records act
actually does
so it does the opposite so not only not
only is he not charged with the
presidential records act right
he's not charged with that which he
probably could be but he's not charged
with that criminally it's the Espionage
Act that he's charged with
he doesn't even know that oh God
apparently it takes a really good lawyer
just to understand the charges he's in
deep [__] because he does not have any
really good lawyers around him anywhere
and here's the thing
this is very very good if you're on the
side of Jack Smith in the doj locking up
Donald Trump for the rest of his [__]
life this is really good because if this
is really his legal defense they will
not they will not
allow this defense in court and the
reason why is because it's not true at
all
right there's nothing that couples this
with any kind of
legal argument
and if this is the argument that his
attorney's plan on making in the court
of law he will lose badly
bad he will lose wildly it is going to
be just incredible how much he loses and
I hope he keeps listening to Tom Fenton
because I believe that this is where
this is coming from Tom fitton has
actually convinced him that this is not
only a good legal strategy but it's a
good political strategy as well because
we know that Tom Fenton is not only not
a lawyer he's not a political strategist
either he's really bad at both of these
things so I hope that Donald Trump keeps
listening to him I hope that Donald
Trump keeps digging
the whole and we we should not take the
shovel out of his hands while he's doing
that that is very very important that we
give him and Republicans in general
just enough rope
to hang themselves in the 2024 election
and I believe that's what he's doing
but I mean this is going to be his
ultimate downfall
this this idea that the presidential
records Act is going to save him
it won't it's not it doesn't even say
what he says it says it says the
opposite of course it's the opposite of
what he says that's really where you
start with Donald Trump you know what I
mean you start there you're like okay
dude you said this I'm gonna go with the
opposite
it's always projection with these idiots
speaking of projection
and the America real America First Nazi
rally there at the turning points event
Lauren bobert made her way to the stage
to project as well let's listen to what
she says about herself it's weird stuff
that is what we need there has been a
moral to a and our country because too
many of our leaders have traded the
truth for a lie
yes you are I can't believe it I cannot
believe it she is absolutely correct
holy [__] yeah man even a broken clock
is right twice a day isn't it holy [__]
Lauren bobert is absolutely correct the
problem is is that she's not looking in
the mirror saying this she's projecting
this onto other people yes
yes Lauren there is moral Decay and the
moral Decay is you you [__] Nazi that
is the moral Decay the fascism is the
moral decay in our country and in our
discourse it is you
a lot of people say um I'm hard on them
I don't you shouldn't call them Nazis
what what do you want me to call them
what would you like me to call you tell
me what to call them and then I'll I'll
consider it but Nazi seems to fit best
it's what they are it's what they're
doing that is the moral decay in this
country
now they've slow walked this moral Decay
since really really the Civil Rights
Movement but into the 1980s with Ronald
Reagan where they really used and
weaponized government and weaponized uh
their their their throws of power all
over the country rather in state
legislators or or the House of
Representatives or the senate or the
presidency they've weaponized they've
weaponized government against us with
their fascism
but Lauren bobert is I and you know what
Gabe Sanchez is here holy moly's back
does he have does he have bug bites does
he no yes no he oh he he sang one second
he he's still trying to set up his
Studio from his uh return here and we're
gonna ask him about
um his uh his trip and also I want to
replay Lauren bobert here for him so can
you hear me
he says he's he says he's good now it's
about time hell Gabe Sanchez welcome
back welcome back welcome back my friend
hey how was the trip how was the trip it
was good it was uh a microphone
microphone microphone
I'm out of here for a few days oh man uh
it was good it was nice to
to have a reset I mean I did I will say
this I did film and release so what was
that while I was I thought you were
gonna say like an only fans I didn't
know exactly no I didn't know where you
were going look I know people are like
oh give me some of that Woody content
you know but I'm like oh look look look
the closest I'll give you is a what was
that going from my car with woods behind
that's good that's good that's good
that's good uh well me what's what's are
Have You released it yet yeah I have
okay let's let's watch that here in just
a bit but I want to show you first did
you did you get a chance I know you were
kind of it and yesterday on patreon
everyone's asking if I talked to you I
said no I'm leaving him alone because
he's out in the woods he's getting bug
bites he's he's he's he's he's cooking
his food over a campfire
got inundated with everything like I
left and then like about an hour outside
of where we were camping it was like
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding and I
was like oh my God I
it was just like a flurry of like
notifications I I don't think I've
gotten through with them all but I was
like oh okay so the audience wanted to
know if you were camping or glamping the
other day no camping so it was camping
camping yeah not glamping camp camping
camping down by the river
man no glamping for okay Sanchez yeah
that guy with the last name Sanchez have
you seen this clip of Lauren bobert
Sanchez I have not there's only okay
there's only one clip I've watched from
turning point USA and it's uh it's with
uh Brian Glenn oh okay okay I I have
seen that one clip because I I did I did
I don't snort all the cocaine Jesus
out of the butt um
the only real video I watched uh was
the Brian Glenn Forgiato blow uh
interview which he's the mega rapper I'm
doing what was that on it because oh my
God is this the mg TG rap video yes yes
don't worry don't worry everyone I will
be educating you all on everything that
is Mega rap which well I can't wait to
watch that one that's the real thing can
you pull that can you pull that clip I'm
gonna show you that this Boba clip while
you're pulling that one the one that you
watch because I wanna I wanna show the
audience the one clip that you watch uh
so they know what this what was that is
going to be about but here is here is
Lauren bobert and again I'm gonna replay
it and I know the audience like don't
replay her but I want to replay it for
you she's I think I think she's talking
about herself here let's see what you
think that is one there has been
[Music]
have traded the truth for a lie but it
says I mean if she's right yeah she's
finally right yeah it's like turning
projection USA is is the name that it
should be because everyone there you had
MTG talking about uh it was LBJ right
she was talking about yeah I'll show
that one that was a dig at Biden and
you've got oh a total dig for him to say
that he's for the social safety net that
everyone relies on it's so totally I
feel like every clip I've heard or seen
has been complete projection to be like
oh these politicians are traded in for
the truth and taken off
it's like okay all right that's what
it's you know what's going on uh that's
the what was that oh okay yeah yeah uh I
can find the one with
yeah with that Brian Glenn MTV let me
show you the Marjorie Taylor green where
she's on the stage projecting and she's
trying to make the case that the social
safety net that we've developed over the
last I don't know 100 years or so is a
bad thing it's all socialism and Joe
Biden is for the social safety net and
definitely we should have never had the
social safety net in the first place
I don't know how many people would agree
with this but uh she apparently does
what's funny is she is a product of the
social safety net if you don't know that
she's a product of the social safety net
but you know I'm not going to go into
details there I love though how on this
uh this is rsbn's uh feed for her
talking about LG LBJ and social safety
net and look what they're advertising
over here on the side buy gold
it's always some it's always some
Financial Scandal like buy gold get into
these things there's no promise that
you'll ever get your money back right
it's like you're sure use your Social
Security that that she's knocking on to
buy gold from us it'll be great it'll be
great let's listen to how she frames up
our social safety net is awful and it
should have never took place in the
first place Lyndon B Johnson is very
similar to Joe Biden how are they the
same they're both Democrat socialists
Lyndon B Johnson was the majority okay
okay first off Linda B Johnson was not
oh let me repeat this he was not a
socialist okay not a socialist he that's
not what Linda be if you go back and
look at Linda B Johnson that's the
opposite of what Lyndon B Johnson was he
was not a socialist that is not
something that Lyndon B Johnson was I
actually recall one of the best
capitalist
um uh uh phone calls that he made have
you ever heard the phone call Linda B
Johnson trying to order a pair of pants
because he doesn't he doesn't want he
doesn't want the seam uh to cut him
under the balls he doesn't want it to
cut his balls in half he's literally
saying this on the bone he's like look
you gotta leave you gotta leave you
gotta leave room for my balls you know
what I mean like he's literally saying
this on the phone to the tailor of a
tailor shop like in Minnesota or some
[__] yeah and it's it's just the epitome
of what uh
never heard that phone call before okay
well we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to um dive into that here soon
um here is here's the rest of what she
says because she she invokes FDR even
and says that Joe Biden is continuing
the work of FDR and LBJ which I'm not
sure why that's a bad thing but let's
see what she thinks later in the Senate
does that sound familiar
he was vice president to Kennedy Joe was
vice president to Obama he was appointed
as the president after JFK was
assassinated then he was elected okay
his big socialist programs were the
Great Society
what's in the Great Society Gabe Sanchez
do you recall what the there's there's a
really popular one in there
started with an M met up met us
something meta who had a metaphor yeah I
can't remember
it's almost like all retired people in
this country kind of rely on it as their
health care provider it's kind of funny
maybe I'm you mean I'm off my rocker you
mean like a like something that you
would like care like you would care like
the like the government would kind of
care or give you care as you get older
maybe and it's not perfect like there's
like like medicinal care right what
that's it that's it it's Medicare that's
what it is now the other thing too the
other thing too about it about the Great
Society is
um
it wasn't complete it really wasn't
complete right it was never intended to
pay for all the bills and because of
when Lyndon B Johnson was the president
at the time medical care just wasn't as
as expensive as it is today right so
it's not complete it's almost like she
knows that it's not complete but it's
all it's not just that it's also the
fact that
when you've got something like that the
same the same way the same way when you
look at the Affordable Health Care Act
you know Obamacare
these are not meant to be one and done
Solutions
these are meant to be building blocks
these are meant to say
here's the starting point
and then the next Administration will
add to it or or the the Congress or the
the Senate they'll add to it to make
sure that it gets better and better
because Gabe said obviously you're
describing government you're describing
government and that's going to be very
good all I gotta say is it it feels like
you would want to you know let's break
it down to Legos man when you got Legos
you stack them together you don't have
the finished version of what's on the
instruction manual when you get it you
have to take the pieces and build them
together set up a foundation follow the
instructions work together if you're you
know happen to be working with another
person
but that's what those are in the same
way that you've got the Great Society
like oh well the Great Society was this
ever anything that is passed is never
supposed to be like it is perfect in its
entirety and will never be have to
change ever again
well she she thinks she thinks the same
thing let's listen
the Great Society where big government
programs to address education
Urban problems rural poverty yeah
Transportation okay Medicare yes
Medicaid yes food stamps yes and Welfare
yes the office of Economic Opportunity
Big labor and labor union that's it yeah
now
LBJ had the Great Society but yes he did
had build back better
and he still is working on it the
largest public investment in Social
infrastructure and environmental
programs that is actually finishing what
FDR started that LBJ expanded on and Joe
Biden is attempting to complete is this
an ad for Joe Biden I'm confused as [__]
here this really sounds like an average
did did someone did someone slip her the
script of a Joe Biden ad for her and
then an FDR and LBJ and yeah why would
why would we not continue to expand this
yeah what gave us prosperity in this
country and it's [__] bonehead it's
not just expanding but it's improving
why wouldn't we as time goes on make it
better for everyone involved right yeah
it just it just feels like there's the
way in which they want to go about these
things it seems weird that she's saying
but this again I keep telling you the
audience like hey okay if we just keep
letting them dig this hole they're gonna
keep getting it deeper and deeper and
we've got to give them just enough rope
and here's the Rope you give her like
literally she is saying a campaign ad
that most Americans would be like yeah
we want education now that sounds good
like we want to get rid of poverty
that's probably a good thing I mean we
want medical care that's affordable yeah
that's that's probably what we want I
and she's saying she's like these are
horrible like with the attitude but
she's reading it as if this is an ad for
Joe Biden let's finish and then we'll
show you why she's such a clown like I
mean this makes her a clown but I'm
really gonna show you what makes her a
clown socialism
meanwhile we are now 32 trillion dollars
in debt with record high homelessness
40-year record inflation we're losing
the US dollar as the number one world
currency we're losing our freedoms our
government is one big fat bloated
machine
and it's killing the American dream
I almost again I almost feel like this
is an ad for Joe Biden she's making a
great case a great case for Democrats
why and why you would expand these
programs because of these problems it
really feels like she doesn't know that
some of the solutions to the problems
that she's talking about are the things
that she hates it really is weird it's
weird stuff but I wouldn't expect anyone
um that does this
uh like I mean let me get this uh
play the one with him and then the the
one with Brian Glenn yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna play the one with the uh the is it
is he called himself Trump's nephew is
that what he calls himself yeah he calls
himself Trump's nephew he's got a lot of
names he's the mayor of magaville he's
Forgiato blow
which I like to call them fellatio blow
well I mean when you're gonna blow you
might as well fellatio and I don't know
if that's because his music blows or he
likes to carry around a trump blow up
though I'm just giving you a preview of
the next what was that everyone he
literally does do that with the Trump
blow up ball you're not making that [__]
up that's real and he's actually got
this shirt on that says MTG my does
it'll make it'll make another appearance
don't worry oh my God okay so here this
is only 11 seconds but I hope you
haven't ate this morning because this
might upset your stomach so don't drink
anything it might uh affect you here in
this 11 seconds let's take a look
Patriots what's up is 4G auto bloated
mayor Mega Bill my new album is out
right now click this
song coming with the megas
and check it out go get the album
Patriot
don't
let those those Communists try to cancel
us Patriots let me tell you I'm Forgiato
blow
you know what's funny some someone
posted a video of his music before he
became like balls in on Trump like
literally on his Trump dull balls deep
yeah um he he he would he would talk
about a lot of stuff that would
conservatives would be like whoa you're
doing what the [__] and hoes that's
really well publicly they might say wow
privately they might be like oh hell
yeah hell yeah I mean if we're gonna
talk about indoctrination let's talk
about the music that this guy makes I'm
sure you do that and then what was that
oh yes of course
no expense oh I go through it all I
[__] drag him through the mud and the
other guy there's another guy called
best believe oh yeah
[__] awful no and there's another
worse than this worse than fellatio blow
he's a little he's a little bit better
than fellatio blow oh okay okay well
here's fellatio blow and his MTG uh
hoodie and his 47 hat I just
just want to give everyone a
a preview or or
prime you for what to expect in this
video I'm gonna make I may or may not
dress up
as
AKA fellatio blow aka the mayor of
magnaville aka the Trump of rap AKA
the worst rapper of all time I I think
this is a what was that we're gonna have
to show on the show oh of course of
course we're gonna have to show it we're
just not gonna be able to get around it
here's the interview with uh mtg's
boyfriend do you think do you think
there was a [__] sandwich that went on
between the three I don't know I heard I
heard I heard bobert non-junior or are
bump and uglies maybe these three are
you know having those cocaine sex orgies
I don't know I I don't want to think
about it you put it there I put it out
there in the universe now you gotta know
it let's see what's in this clip that
you sent me I'm excited about not being
excited about these two let's let's hear
it you uh sent me the rough version of
that track and I was amazed I was like
well how long would it take you to write
this and your answer surprisingly 10
minutes 10 minutes because what I do you
guys work through tonight it's an
amazing video it just dropped about an
hour ago uh it's blowing up of course
the left hates it Ron flipakowski can't
stand
oh they hate Ron don't they yeah they
they they uh they're like Ron
flipakowski Patriot takes right and
patriotics is like all right we're gonna
share every other video okay got the
enemy so Ron's like and that post that I
just showed from Ron Ron's like oh okay
you're gonna say my name yeah of course
I'm gonna [__] it's wait I want to
show you I want to show you something
here because
um Trump's
nephew
is that is that real is this one wait
Trump's nephew is his account click on
it yeah I know that's him yeah okay so
that'll blow 47 so this is this is Ron's
post of the video okay if you go down
you can see here he is 10 minutes run
because it's all truth you you used to
love Maga too bad you sold out
Ron Ron Ron two wrong two God bless it
here I was thinking this guy was a
lyrical genius I know I know Brian or
proficionado Ron says no man I was a
republican who never voted Trump
uh also you see Fred Willman here in the
comments he says no you're now you're a
music critic music music
Ron quotes do a lot of work there Fred
we're gonna have Fred Wellman on this
week he's on Thursday I just want to
tell the audience that that's why I I
brought Fred up there because Fred's
going to be on Thursday so don't miss
Thursday's show uh we're actually
tomorrow's Texas uh Paul Tuesday so he's
gonna be on and then Wednesday Wednesday
I believe we're gonna have major ogetta
Richard Ojeda is going to be back on the
show so just a few announcements there
as I'm as I'm making my way through
okay so should we show the what was that
now or should we do a little more going
back and forth and then oh my God wait a
second wait a second wait a second are
you gonna play the video
um you know what I'm gonna play the what
was that here but I yeah no I'm saying
like play the music video you can you
can just show people what what kind of
music this guy well I think this is a
new release of it this is a um this is
the actual track that he was trying to
release and the song he was trying to do
here now let's let's see Wing here
videos
[Music]
only reason that you see us
okay
I like the remix way better than the
original That Remix was so much better
uh the song the song uh gave a little
taste of uh yeah I think made a couple
references to some things that will show
up oh yeah okay what was that remix is
way better okay I'm just I just want to
tweak this out there and just so people
understand the song that we just played
is not the actual song that's it's a
song making fun of that right right
right well you know you gotta do what
you gotta do you know what I mean uh
mocking them sure mocking them is more
important than anything all right so
what what what is this uh what was that
that you sent over let's let's let's go
to that was that yeah what was that is
uh it's all about Michael and Dell and
my pillow oh you know that's that's
great welcome that's great because uh
the news on Mike Lindell is that he
might be broke is that right is that
kind of his flat broke uh is that kind
of what you go through here yeah pretty
much okay all right I pull the receipts
out I show the people what's up as I do
with what was that oh well let's go to
what was that with Gabe Sanchez welcome
to what was that I'm Gabe Sanchez the
unhinged Mike Lindell seems to have
gotten his company my pillow in so much
financial trouble after retailers cut
ties following his crazy election claims
that it's now having to auction off its
equipment so but before we jump into
that make sure to like this video
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already and ring that notification Bell
so you never miss another what was that
episode or a comedic sketch for me now
if you've been living under a rock
shaped like pillow let me catch you up
to speed Mike Lindell the
self-proclaimed my pillow guy and
election denier extraordinaire is back
in the news except this time it turns
out his company my pillow is having a
bit of a rough time you know the company
that claims to give you the best sleep
of your life while simultaneously
assaulting you with endless infomercials
hello I'm Mike Mendel inventor of my
pillow thanks to your support you've
helped make my pillow become one of the
fastest growing companies in America
over the last 12 years you've held my
pillow create thousands of jobs right
here in the USA well that commercial
aged poorly oh and don't worry Mike
lindell's commercials only got more
creepy as time went on
looks like you're not sleeping well yeah
how did you know
Megan
hey you're that guy from my pillow guy
only Michael indel could come up with an
idea to appear in someone's medicine
cabinet like something out of a bootleg
horror movie and no matter how many of
these commercials that Lindell has made
they have not helped him from losing
business due to his wild conspiracies
you see my pillow recently lost so many
retailers that they're planning to host
a little auction to make up for their
losses
160. the last time I heard a Company
Auction office equipment was Twitter
when Elon Musk was trying to sell office
supplies including chairs a pizza oven
and a neon bird sign I mean Elon was so
desperate to boost the company's income
that he tried to sell Twitter's office
plans to staff it's almost like
Republicans are terrible at business I
mean call me crazy but I don't believe
it's smart to platform Nazis racist
rapists and human traffickers you know
like misogynist Andrew Tate no wonder
Twitter users are flocking to threads
even Twitter employees enjoy threads
over Twitter oh and by the way if you're
there feel free to say hello and follow
me at I am Gabe Sanchez anyway Lindell
has been losing retailers left and right
Walmart Costco Bed Bath and Beyond and
Slumberland Furniture which I had never
even heard of until this very moment all
of these big box retailers have dropped
ties with Lindell because he can't keep
his conspiracy theories in his
pillowcase maybe Lindell should have
focused on making his pillows great
again instead of making baseless claims
about election fraud according to Mike
Lindell it was a massive massive
cancellation we lost a hundred million
dollars from attacks by the box stores
the shopping networks the shopping
channels all of them did cancel culture
on us it's not cancel culture it's
called not working with a [__]
lunatic that's called business 101. my
pillow recently listed more than 850
Surplus equipment items on the online
auction site kbid sewing machines
industrial fabric spreaders forklifts
and even desks and chairs are up for
auction he's even selling trucks which
makes me think that this is going to be
a permanent hit to Lindell not only that
but the company is now having to
sublease some of its manufacturing space
who knows maybe Lindell is using this
auction to cushion the blow since
plunging sales are not lindell's only
financial problem at Mike lindell's 2021
cyber imposium he had a five million
dollar challenge for experts to examine
his data with a proved Micron contest
which he claimed proved that Donald
Trump really won the 2020 election
there's a five million dollar prize for
anybody that can that can prove the
election data that that I have from the
2020 election is false well guess what
someone proved Mike wrong I mean not
that it was that difficult to do
considering the wild claims that Lindell
was making and after the winner demanded
the prize money Lindell refused to pay
sure sounds like he's taking cues from
his BFF Trump well it is the reality is
fake it's the biggest Scandal
um here I am on a family trip with my
grandkids and I got attacked from all
over the country at news reporters
called me all day isn't it kind of
strange just comes out the day after Fox
settles with Dominion this guy is not a
cyber guy I don't even know how he got
in there with his credentials he has
he's an I.T guy a computer guy but he's
not a cyber guy not a cyber guy but an
I.T guy I'm sorry what does Lindell
think that it stands for Imaginary
techies Intergalactic thinkers internet
troublemakers though I wouldn't be
surprised if Lindell actually thinks I.T
is that creepy sewer clown from The
Stephen King novel
aren't you gonna say hello
oh come on
Don't You Wanna balloon regardless the
prove Mike wrong challenge ended up
going to court and surprise surprise
Mike Lindell lost let's just start off
here right he puts this challenge out
there he says that it would have to be
arbitrated and you take it all the way
to the Finish Line what's your reaction
today when you find out you've been
awarded five million dollars from Mike
Lindell
well Aaron thanks for having me and I
think it was uh relief not because uh I
I doubted my own findings the in fact I
never expected to be able to show that
it was bogus data because normally data
analysis could take weeks or months and
I had three days but the data was so
obviously fake that I spent a few hours
before I could show it was fake I always
worried though Mike Lindell has a lot of
resources a lot of money and you never
know I you know I think the court system
generally justices served but not always
and so I was never sure if I was going
to be awarded the money and more than
the money I really wanted the people the
public to know what was going on well
and and that's what you've accomplished
I mean amazing you'd say you think it
would take you you know it could take
you months took you hours essentially um
that that's that's how difficult it was
to debunk to make the point
um Mike Lindell you just heard he told
CNN that this will end up in support do
you think you'll ever get the five
million dollars that Lindell has been
ordered to pay you
unfortunately I don't think so it would
be nice and I don't think it's because
of court I think if he does go to court
if he does appeal I think it's going to
be thrown out uh but unfortunately I
don't think he has a case against
Dominion or I should say Dominion has a
great case against him and Dominion of
course is asking for I think 1.2 billion
and I don't think Lindell has that so I
think uh I'm afraid he's going to be out
of money before I ever see my 5 million
he actually makes a pretty good point
here because based on the way that my
pillow is going he may never see that
five million dollars you'd think that if
you're going to offer a five million
dollar prize you'd better know what
you're talking about and not be full of
fluff but no matter how many times
Lindell has proven wrong he continues to
stand by his debunked claims insisting
that machines were used to steal the
election and we're doing a class action
I'm announcing it here I announced it on
my program y'all watchfrankspeech.com
don't come keep watching
um they um but it's a class action
lawsuit against all machines and that
their defective devices what kind of
machines are we talking about here
vending machines pinball machines coin
machines we definitely need to go after
those woke washing machines I mean the
pillow man is so invested in his own
delusion that he invested 40 million
dollars I've spent over 40 million
dollars unbelievable hang on a second
he's spent over 40 million dollars I've
spent in a uh and uh I need help well
you're right about that you definitely
need some help what we're doing with
praying speech within the next couple
weeks uh could be for two to four weeks
we're offering stock to the public this
is going to be amazing we're offering
stock to the public I want every person
out there to have a little piece of the
pie for our boys for this country
seriously the grift never stops with a
GOP Lindell even has plans to host an
event in August detailing a new way to
hold elections so on top of fact that
Lindell is facing a 1.3 billion dollar
defamation suit from dominion over his
lies about the 2020 election as well as
my pillow losing business because of
said wild claims Lindell decided that
he's just going to double down by
hosting an election Summit Lindell
believes that his upcoming event along
with the evidence that he submitted to
dominion and smart Matic in his cases
will lead to a cinematic ending like in
my cousin Vinnie what seriously Mike
Lindell thinks he has a chance to win
his case against these two youths two
what what did you say Utes yeah two Utes
well that's all for me today thanks so
much for watching this episode of what
was that if you want to see more videos
like this make sure to like this video
subscribe to this Channel and turn on
notifications and of course if you want
even more content like this you can
always follow me on Instagram at I am
Gabe Sanchez and you can support my work
by joining my community at patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez
so there it is there's the what was that
with Gabe Sanchez there boom mike that's
what I was doing while I was uh
well like right before I was like right
yeah right before I was camping pretty
much I see I see well I I have to tell
you that the uh what was that the
production on it you're you're getting
wild there's like the the cut ends the
cutouts yeah you know I'm trying to work
it works good in the back of the car I
started so here yeah I so I started the
what was that as like I'm in the studio
right I'm hearing it and then I've
slowly changed it to be more kind of
YouTubey you know
um because people have you know short
attention spans so I gotta [__]
splice and jump on it do all this stuff
I gotta change around but I am curious I
am curious if people wanna I will do a
live poll right now uh here actually let
me let me go put it on the YouTube
channel yeah let me let me get into the
studios
I have a question for everyone and it's
about the set I would like to know
because I've done multiple versions of
the set where I've been in I had the
brick wall then I had the other Studio
was a green screen I was like ah [__] I
don't want to keep doing this green
screen [__] and then I had to switch
over to the car because uh car works
good I like the car the audio is good in
the car the audio is good in the cup
well yeah I mean it's great great cards
super super good padding so what I'm
curious and I will make this poll right
now is I want to know do you and the
previous ones I think you played one
while I was gone which is yeah
um which is actually in the room here
but it's using the color lights right
right yeah yeah it's not it that's
that's not a background that you did in
the computer that's a background you do
with lighting yeah yeah so that one what
I'm curious about is is people like I'm
sorry I'm trying to get in here it's
loading kind of slowly but what I would
be curious to know is
do uh I'll start a poll all right
should game use the car or
the car or his Studio he colored the
colorful
Studio
for what was that so then put in car
Studio as the options car studio so you
guys are gonna vote here on YouTube we
haven't done many YouTube polls we
should do these more as we go along yeah
the problem is it's just me and you so
they're right yeah sometimes we know and
and I can't believe that YouTube doesn't
give us the ability to let the
moderators do it either but they I know
that is that is kind of messed up man I
don't I don't like uh it's weird I don't
like that but anyways that's YouTube the
YouTube hates us you know and people are
already giving Chats on Facebook here uh
Facebook they're saying car
okay uh Carey says on Facebook studio
and car so they like a you know kind of
a you know like uh like you know some
some flavor right this time this time
this time that time um on YouTube studio
uh car there Studio on Facebook so I
think I think the consensus is probably
going to be 50 50. you can use
okay can you use both at the same time
[Music]
um
well you know you know that would be
kind of that would be kind of weird and
I think they're saying both like you can
go back and forth okay okay I don't
think the background matters to the
audiences the content that you provide
gotcha I think that's what it is and if
you want to see more of that content
that Gabe provides go to what was
thatshow.com or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez to get more of the content there
go join his patreon support him in the
effort to make what was that I think
there's going to be more and more what
was that's coming I really like I said
there's I've got uh I've got this one on
Forgiato AKA fellatio blow and MTG and
then I also I've got another one coming
up on Rhonda santis and Casey DeSantis
uh of their anti-lgbtq because I don't
know if people know this but Rhonda
Sanchez before before I left for camping
I was able to make it but uh before I
left for camping last week
the group that released that very
homophobic disgusting ad against the
lgbtq community yeah it's like
anti-trump for supporting lgbtq rights
it turns out that they quietly deleted
that video they just deleted it they
deleted it they didn't even want to they
didn't want people to know so they like
just like killed it and then some people
spotted it
it's almost like they were ashamed of it
it's almost like which which is crazy
because like less than 48 hours before
that Ron DeSantis was talking with uh
[__] Tommy Tomy tomay Tommy whatever
the [__] her name whatever her name is
the one who got uh Nazi Lauren the one
who got gender affirming uh care yes
surgery uh
interviewed Ron DeSantis Rhonda Santos
was like oh and he doubled down on it
and he's like oh not my problem uh
whatever so
I
I got I feel like I gotta do it because
not only that because Casey DeSantis
also released an ad that attacked the
lgbtq community and I think I think
she's the one that's actually behind
this this campaign I'm not being honest
I think she's the one that's doing it
and Rhonda Sanchez because he's not he's
very vanilla right he's a robot he's an
Android he just takes commands
I'm not the Android in a skin suit yeah
exactly right and I think that she's the
one
who is who is the brainchild behind this
homophobic content and she's like oh
okay yeah I'll do it and he's like oh
yeah I'll make the video or oh yeah I
totally support this video well if you
want to see that what was that that's
coming up uh um questioning rather Casey
DeSantis behind that today go to
patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez it's patreon.com while
you're on patreon visit mine too but
definitely go check out Gabe's David one
more comment here on where to do what
was that um he said I don't give a duck
ah that sounds good you know it works
for me
a question uh the mods picked up what
did I eat while I was camping in the
woods yeah
um all right so the first night we were
there uh we made we made burgers on the
on the fire uh the next morning we had
uh eggs and bacon
the next day or for that later that day
I think we just made sandwiches then we
went up I was in Big Sur so I went up to
the gorge
um which is like a a natural spring kind
of waterfall uh did we make tacos yes we
did make sure
veggie tacos because we had a we had a
couple people who were vegetarians so we
had
um sauteed we cooked up some mushrooms
in the pan over the fire and then we
also had uh refried beans cheese
uh what else we have and there's like
some sauce on some other things yeah ooh
campfire Tacos yeah and of course we had
hot dogs one night of course of course
right over the fire you have hot dogs
right and you burn them like they're
black and crispy that's how yeah exactly
so I want to go back to um no we were
not and somebody said that's gramping I
don't know what gramping is do you mean
glamping that's not glamping glamping
would be like I went to a cabin or was
it right hey there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong with the clamping
but this one was a you know a natural
camping trip you're you know you got
your tent and you got your everything
else and you're one with nature and a
river which was kind of nice except
there was a campsite nearby that was
there was one person that was [__]
snoring so loud oh really and it was
almost comical it was like grizzly bear
[Music]
just like that just like that it was
like a cartoon it was like a cartoon
that's great that's great so you had you
had entertainment as well yeah yeah so I
want to go back to part of something
that was mentioned in the what was that
about
um Tucker Carlson Andrew Tate so we all
know that uh Tucker Carlson did an
interview with Andrew Tate and and they
really tried to normalize human sex
trafficking in this interview it's
really kind of weird the way they did it
um the thing that most people and I
pointed out is that just days before
they were making fun of Joe Biden for
not wearing shoes on the beach and his
shoes
excuse me that's right no socks with the
shoes yeah he was doing the old Don
Johnson and this is this is always
Andrew tape he's always like he does
this man spreading
yeah their power move is it the power
move which is funny because when you do
this you go like this and people like oh
Illuminati Illuminati the Deep State and
then here's this guy going like this so
he's Illuminati he's the Deep State I
think well here people who know the Deep
State talk about the Deep state but you
see both these two have on very fancy
um loafers I personally love them that's
got money on it yeah that's uh
interesting too
um but what is interesting about this
interview is that it is not what it
seems but it is funny though that all
these people are in um you know simping
for Andrew Tate including one of our
favorites in Mario's rooms soliman oh my
God this [__] oh of course dude this
is
last time I talked to him in the room
he's like Tony my boy I'm like I'm not
your boy yeah ah I'm not you I'm not
your [__] boy all right I am not your
[__] boy okay you you may think that
I am but I am not your [__] boy right
I told that to him in the room but um it
is interesting that you know do you know
that Solomon uh Sully man whatever it is
yeah uh did you know that and supposedly
he's got kids I don't know if that's
true really wow but he also said wow he
also said he also said in a in a um
as spaces yeah he said that he was
pain for the whatever the [__] Alpha
University whatever the [__] is called
oh Hustler Universe Hustler University
that's what it is he said he was paying
for that for his kids
which which if he does actually have
kids I'm not surprised that is something
he doesn't I'm sure that he will if he
does have kids oh my God it's this it's
almost the same as the one rich dad
taking his son in the uh in the little
little Excursion down to the Titanic
like why would you do that to you why
would you take your children into the
abyss like that but you know hey
parental rights man do what you want to
do but this video is interesting
um this is from Milk Bar TV and this is
a compilation not only of the Tucker
Carlson interview but also of interviews
that Andrew Tate has done talking about
how he human trafficks women yeah this
is his own words and of course in the in
the Twitter thread soliman's like this
is all taken out of Conte text okay well
let's watch and see the context that
it's taken out of Let's watch what are
you charged with that's a really good
question I'm charged with being the head
of an organized criminal Group which is
in charge of recruiting girls to make
Tick Tock videos they face charging okay
well I'm gonna stop there did you see
that he was flexing his pecs as he was
he's always doing this he's always like
his posture because I mean look the guy
is a a sociopath if there was ever a
living embodiment yeah of American
Psycho this is it that is he's not
American though no okay a lot a lot of a
lot of white a lot of white Americans
love him right right I mean look at here
go back to the beginning of the video
yeah I can reap I'm let's just replay
the whole yeah I'll play the whole thing
in the entirety just open up no look at
the back that's a photo of him in
a horse
it's like a chest it's like a chess
piece here this is a photo this is a oh
God damn it okay this is a photo of him
what I believe because he can't go
anywhere because he's on house arrest
while he's still being charged and stuff
he's still being detained yeah so he
just left the jail the prison and now
he's at his home this is his office he
has a gorilla with money around it he
has a painting drawing some sort of
with a fire horse or a phoenix or some
dumb [__] like that in his what I assume
is his office
and that that's the type of person that
he is wait wait wait wait by what looks
like does he have it does he have a dick
Shadow because I got a dick Shadow I
don't know I did not see a dick shadow
in the in the versions of this okay well
though I haven't inspected to I was
debating if I should do this as a what
was that I don't know yet but it might
be too late okay well let's let's watch
this version this is a long version
we're gonna go a little long here
watching this but I think it's worth
watching this uh to to show you actually
who Andrew Tate his Andrew Tate is in
his own words watch what are you charged
with that's a really good question I'm
charged with being the head of an
organized criminal Group which is in
charge of recruiting girls to make Tick
Tock videos they face charges which
include human trafficking rape and
forming a criminal gang to sexually
exploit only fans is the best hustle in
the world are they accusing you of using
violence or no
accuse me of using the Loverboy method
coercing them by being nice I don't
mention webcam
until after I've had sex with a girl if
you're on dates and you're trying to
mention it and [__] it just doesn't work
it puts them off I'd never do that
that's disgusting I'm not a [__] uh
it's just not gonna work
you continue as normal no mention of
webcam you [__] the girl after you
[__] the girl you do the PHD test so
yeah on covertake.com I have my PhD
program and that is uh PhD is a Pimpin
hoes degree that I'm
[Music]
um
that teaches basically how I got girls
how I met girls how I got girls to like
me how I got girls to fall in love with
me to work on webcam for me oh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together we're for
you doing once they'll have a webcam
business oh I don't want to do that so
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't do it fine let me explain
it to you properly in fact I'll bring
one of the girls who works through
Bolton [__] is the one who does the
selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear it from a girl this is
where your bottom [__] to be trained
so I said it's so important to have a
good first girl because that's what I
did that was my my Mo was fine girls
make them love me and make them work for
me this girl's like okay well I'll try
it put both girls on camera together the
first day so the new girl can sit in
there and just sit with the other girl
and get drunk give him a bowl of vodka
last night that I worked for him and you
bought me like five bottles of wine so I
got completely drunk because I never
done webcam work so I was very very
nervous and that's how I got rich so
that teaches everything I know from
start to finish about uh not only
getting girls not only obtaining them
but retaining them because that's a
completely different game as well over
time I just build up this painting this
big Empire of webcam girls at one one
point I had four locations 75 girls
working for me I'd take around half of
the money around 50. around 50 they
thought they were on fifty percent uh-oh
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes he would just pay me a
flat fee of 15 pounds an hour we got to
the point where these guys falling in
love with my models serious big time in
love right sending crazy money and they
were convinced they were gonna meet the
chick this is almost where I kind of
felt bad because they're like can we
meet a thousand dollars when you look at
the money that I was actually bringing
in it just doesn't even scratch the surf
yes I had these guys selling their
houses life savings loans all of it to
me give me it all I was all about trying
to get paid like my whole I use sex as a
tool to make women love me so they'd
obey me and live in my house and make me
money that's what I wanted so I was a
pimp in that sense were there any other
instances where there was physical abuse
I saw him
smack girls with a belt oh my dear
you're not my ideas
have you behaved I wouldn't have to hit
you would I
he's wrong get out
you can't stay in there forever once
again this is an IQ test right because
any guy who's bad with women would look
at it and go takes a woman beater I say
it look at the camera
listen look at the camera
any man who's actually a Jeep who's been
around a little bit would look at the
video and go man she looked she wants
that the media machine they'd call up
ex-girlfriends and say if you have
anything bad to say about Andrew we can
pay you fifty thousand dollars for the
story and they tried very hard
they didn't find any evidence of
anything and I had gone to the shower
while I came back and I noticed he was
I saw him raping her
people say one in Romania and I explain
my five reasons one of them is to meet
you Era think oh well you're a rapist I
said no I'm a [__] rapist but I like
the idea of being able to just say to do
what I want I like being free and of
course they don't go out they're not
allowed out you stay in the house
because I'm I'm not particularly
what would you say impressed by what
he's done on the
sex business front even Jordan Peterson
pimpy side let's say I get called a
pimple law but I and the reason I use
the term is because I don't see it as a
negative term I see it as positively
inspirational and motivating person she
has to respect you and love you and want
to work with you and that's done through
positive
pimp positively inspirational and
motivating person I'm gonna send you a
book it's a guy called Pimpin Ken who's
a street pimp in the 90s and he wrote a
book uh 50 laws of the game and one of
the laws of the game is a hoe without
instruction is headed for Destruction
accusing me of using the Loverboy method
coercing them by being nice let me read
you then what you have said about what
you have done sure you have said my job
was to meet a girl go on a few dates
sleep with her get her to fall in love
with me to the point where she'd do
anything I say and then get her on
webcam so we could become rich together
I don't think that's what I personally
said I think that's exactly what you
said on your website that's no I've
never said that so yeah on corporate.com
I have my PhD program the I think the
belief is that you were charged with
human trafficking yeah that's human
trafficking because what you do is you
force a girl to work against her will
for financial gain that's human
trafficking and they're yep purification
for this is that girls do Tick Tock some
girls I know who they've found who say
they're not victims have Tick Tock
accounts PhD is a Pimpin hoes degree
[Music]
um
clever the most that is a person
well okay first off Andrew Tate's a
[__] piece of [__] scumbag [__]
absolute trash okay the worst human out
there
that it that is putting himself on
public display and the fact that he got
he has those moments like PhD pimp and
hoes degree like
and then the guy like there was a pause
and then I think he reacted after a
moment but the fact that
that Andrew Tate was like oh man this is
a good one I came up with it myself
Pimpin hoe's degree PhD
shut the [__] up
shut the f I hope this guy goes to jail
I hope that he 100 percent absolutely
finds out
because he's [__] around
and I guarantee he's going to find out
in jail in prison well you know the
reason why I bring it up is because
Tucker Carlson did this interview on
Twitter okay folks and he's trying to
normalize and trying to retell and
whitewash the story of Andrew Tate and
it is clear what Andrew Tate did in his
own [__] words it is clear what he
did it's not taken out of context I want
to show you this this tweet from this
[__] that's in these uh spaces all
times as a co-host which makes me really
think that I should be in these spaces
anymore but uh only to rebut this
[__] [__] uh solomonaire says
this has been taken out of context and
has been refuted by my threads I said
did he pimp you too you [__] idiot
what a [__] bonehead I'm gonna
retweet this go after this guy on
Twitter if you want I'm just saying not
not after him just get in his comments
this is also I don't know if I don't
know if you know this Tony but allegedly
he was uh it's uh hold on hold on hold
on hold on uh [__] what's his last name
uh here here I'll give you I'll give you
his handle here 's his handle
are you talking about Twitter
yeah yeah okay okay yeah it's almond
almond but his handle is different right
no that's fine that's fine so there's a
uh I think it's a guardian article and
I'll have you pull it up right now but
basically there's a connection between
his involvement
uh here's what I want to say while
you're finding that because the reason
why I
point out Solomon because he is in these
[__] spaces and I talk to him and
again he called me his boy one time and
he's based on like I'm not your [__]
boy okay I'm not your [__] boy don't
don't go there because I'm not your
[__] boy but here's the thing is that
all these [__] [__] that you see
on Twitter or anywhere else on the
internet that are saying really wild
[__] in your [__] comments they watch
Andrew Tate videos they watch this
[__] human trafficker this guy who
brags about human trafficking women and
then Tucker Carlson normalizes him for
the same [__] audience that he's not
a sex trafficker
and he's not only that it seems like the
Hustler University thing he's training
sex traffickers wait wait wait wait wait
wait
grooming yeah that could possibly be
again are you telling me that that
Andrew Tate is grooming men
to emotionally verbally physically
abuse women well it seems like he's
doing a lot more than just that but yes
that seems like one thing that he's
doing um here is the article that you're
you're referring to what what what is
significant about the article here okay
so it turns out because I didn't know
this until somebody brought it up it was
actually somebody that was like anti-uh
uh anti
Mario in the space okay gotcha and there
basically this article is about Andrew
Tate and there's another article out
that I'm trying to find I think it might
be a guardian article I but don't quote
me on that
basically connecting Salomon and Andrew
Tate and Salomon if you go type it it
says Salomon Ahmed a protate online
personality on February 18 tweeted that
he had traveled to Palm Beach Florida
the hometown of one of the key Witnesses
in the case
is a lawyer right that's what he says he
says he's a lawyer I don't know he
actually is I mean people say a lot of
things online and turns out that most of
the time they're lying so when I hear
things like someone say I'm a lawyer and
I studied this it's like I don't know I
just think like you
enjoy semantics and you that's all he
does he's like bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro it's like shut up man
I'm not your bro right I'm not your bro
don't call me your bro I'm not your boy
that's not a thing as a Connecting Point
between thoughts doesn't make you sound
any more intelligent you know the thing
that you know the thing that really
really tipped me off that soliman uh is
is a tate dude is because he talks about
the Deep State and the Matrix [__] oh
all the time oh here here's that part of
that article here's the part of the
article so it says yeah Solomon Ahmed a
protein Island personality on February
18 tweeted that he had traveled to Palm
Beach Florida the hometown of one of the
key Witnesses in the case for a
quote-unquote major story however there
was no indication Ahmed who did not
respond to BuzzFeed for comment actually
met the witnesses family now in this
Twitter space when there was some Mario
stuff brought up I think it was that guy
Joe the guy that like basically is like
a Joe Pesci yeah yeah yeah and he's
really anti-mario yeah anti-mario but
Solomon came on to defend Mario and then
people were like oh actually you know
what let's pull up all of your receipts
Solomon and there was an accusation that
was made and I don't know if you can
probably I mean I'm sure people have
documented on Twitter and elsewhere but
basically the accusation was that
Solomon had gone to Florida to
intimidate
these this witness but claiming that he
went there with his family I'm just
there to go visit so so he's there for
business for Tate it seems yes so not
only is he a hustler University fan and
a member and he's he's a tate semp but
it seems that he's working he's working
for today so he went there claiming that
it was there for his family but it just
so happened to be at the same time that
all this was dropping he went to went to
Florida this witness was there and he
publicly was tweeting about it
and there's there's receipts that people
pulled out but basically the the
accusation right is that he was
intimidating or was attempting to
intimidate right the witness uh Williams
here on on YouTube says Tony that was
sickening I hope I never have to see it
again listen I the reason why I showed
the video that video specifically is
because it does such a great job and
Andrew Tate's own words of describing
him and I know and I know most people
may not know who he is because he's a
right-wing uh white male in cell
influencer
um but it is important because this is
where the misogyny is coming from this
is where the nonsense is coming from
people like Tate Nick Fuentes and others
this is where it is breeding from this
right-wing crap this right-wing misogyny
that thinks they have the right I mean
he even says it in the one part of the
video in his own words he's like that's
not rape I just want to be able to do
whatever I want to do yeah
that that's rape you don't get to just
rape someone you don't just get to have
sex with someone who doesn't want to
have sex because that's called rape
that's [__] rape by definition you
cannot move to another country where you
believe and have been told that the
Romanian laws are more lacks because you
want to be able to rape just because
some country may not follow through or
believe that something like that is rape
right it's still rape you're still
taking advantage the person did not give
consent and you want to be in a place
where you are free
of criminal prosecution for taking
advantage of someone it's sick well and
Williams I'll tell you that I understand
that you don't want to watch that
specific video again but I'm trying to
show you where all this stuff is
breeding from I go through YouTube
um like shorts and I'm like flipping
through shorts and Andrew Tate always
ends up in my [__] feed always some
[__] clip of him talking about how a
man should be a man or some [__] and
that's the grooming that he does he's
like oh you should work out you should
get muscles you should be tough you
should fight you should you should be
the wrong reasons right right but he's
grooming these men into thinking this
[__] so that way he can get him into
Hustler University to take their money
too because what he does is he not only
makes money with human sex trafficking
with women he takes [__] his
followers money by trying to act like
he's gonna train them to do the same
stupid [__] and and Williams it is very
important that we do not look away from
this I'm telling you this is one of the
deep-seated problems that we have in
real life where the online Universe of
this white male in cell misogynistic
where women have no value human value at
all
it trickles down into real life it is so
important and Tucker Carlson here is
actually the really [__] awful one
where he's trying to normalize it and
Elon Musk is also [__] awful by
letting Tucker Carlson not only that
promoting the interview and like oh this
is an interesting interview with for a
person for a person piles of [__] for
like Elon Musk that has allegedly been
connected to Jeffrey Epstein that's what
people are saying had a photo with uh
right with what's her face the other
terrible person and Williams I want to
make sure real quick I want to make sure
I wasn't attacking you I know what
you're saying but I just want to tell
you how important it is not to look away
from this stuff we can't hide our eyes
from the truth we can't hide our eyes
from where this sickening bile stuff is
coming from because if we do we won't be
able to combat it we just won't we won't
be able to show the world that hey the
reason why you're thinking this way is
because you're being washed you're being
brainwashed into thinking of stupid [__]
that isn't real it's not true and it's
vile growth stuff and to give you to
give you an idea of the type of people
and you know I Apollo I want to
apologize I I the mods are saying that
some people in the chat said it's
triggering for those who have uh yes it
suffered abuse and I'm I'm so sorry I I
really do apologize if this is and I
want to make sure that you understand
that there are people you know like
ourselves and others that are calling
this out right you know and to give you
an example of the type of people that
are on Twitter like if you were to you
know the dark dark contrast between
threads and Twitter right now in terms
of the type of content and also the
types of dialogue or monologues in many
ways are happening but on Twitter I
posted a screenshot and I said
you know it had I think close to 20
million
views at that time and I said remember
these are not views these are
Impressions okay we just had chatted the
day before I think where we talked about
how their each of these videos that hit
all these episodes that Tucker Carlson
are released have been less and less and
less and less it was becoming less
popular then Tucker releases a two and a
half hour interview with Andrew Tate
platforming him to say this is normal
this guy's not a monster then Elon Musk
who's desperate for views desperate for
attention and desperate to have any sort
of uh validation or recognition for his
hard work that he did on Twitter by
saying interesting right add cobra Tate
I had people in my comments where I said
hey man this is this is a rapist this is
a human trafficker look at this Elon is
of course feeling that he should
platform another monster like himself
and the people in my comments I'm like
oh this is [__] gross I would never
watch this and I just took a screenshot
I didn't I didn't want to replay the
video or anything
and they were people and they're like oh
I watched it two and a half hours with
my wife oh we thought it was very
interesting now some of those people I'm
sure Bots but some of those people were
like oh yeah I watch it what's so wrong
with this this guy's speaking truth it's
the matrix it's the Deep State you got
to listen to what Tucker's saying you
got to listen what Andrew Tate is saying
you got to listen to everything because
they are speaking the truth and people
like you
pointed at me are trying to silence them
and I'm like look I do not have the
Broadband the reach the influence to
silence these two in cells on this
in-cell network right
but I'm gonna call it out and people
were getting very upset and I was like
all of you guys are showing your true
selves right now by saying that this is
an interesting interview and we should
watch it to understand like one person
was like I don't like Andrew Tate and I
don't like Elon Musk and I don't like
Tucker Carlson but I at least have the
the the the appreciation to understand
and I'm like I don't need to understand
these terrible people right why don't
what their justification is for human
trafficking right and say like I'm gonna
justify this like you are doing he's
like I'm not justifying I was like yes
you are because you're trying to explain
that we should sit down and and
understand where they're coming from I
don't [__] have to do that [__] and
that's why I believe that sunlight is
the best disinfectant and I know some
people are triggered by this and what
you should do by being triggered is to
engage you really should you should
engage in in what is happening on social
media with some of these idiots if you
see someone in your comments if you see
someone in your comments saying some
weird crazy [__] ask them are you a
member of Hustler University and if they
say yes you say well now it makes sense
yeah now it makes sense you support
human sex traffickers I see now I see
what your comment is about I see why
you're saying this you're brainwashed by
a human sex trafficker because it's
probably the truth
it's probably the truth we got the
results here for the poll uh Studio says
53 car says 47. I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say that's a 50. that's pretty close
that's pretty close to 50 50. there's a
margin of error there because a lot of
people on Facebook were typing in so my
guess is that Gabe it doesn't matter
which studio you're in which background
you have just keep doing what was that
is the most important thing again if you
want to see the what was that if you
want to see the patreon I hope you do
one on the take Tech or interview just
go to what was that show.com or go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check out
the what was that there while you're on
patreon.com come over to my page too
you'll see what we're about we did a
Sunday rant yesterday we had a lot of
fun it was a Sunday rent and asked me
anything we did like an hour and a half
or something like that yesterday and
Sunday there's very fun got to hang out
with you guys on patreon so go check
that out on patreon.com also if you're
here on YouTube right now and you're not
subscribed hit subscribe and if you
haven't hit like make sure you like
before you leave we're wrapping up here
we're over time but make sure you hit
the like button also follow us on
Twitter while it's still alive I think
maybe I don't know one's still alive I
don't know I'm really hoping that
threads get pulled soon so we can take
the bonehead pull off yeah Twitter I
know that sounds crappy but you know it
is what it is also if you want to watch
the show live you can watch it on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels if you
still have a Facebook account or you're
still brave enough to go on Facebook you
can go over there you can follow us on
Twitch for free as well it's free to
follow us on Twitch I know it's weird
it's free to follow us on Twitch and
then it costs money to subscribe but
it's free to subscribe on YouTube it's
all confusing but it's all free the show
is free just follow us everywhere you
can go and what you can do what you can
do is you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can follow all the
places that the show is aired you all
show what you should do is you should
download every single audio episode
every afternoon on Apple Spotify and
Google get us in the rankings download
every single afternoon on your favorite
platform get us in those ranking
we appreciate it Gabe I'm so glad you're
back we got great guests this week
tomorrow of course it's Tuesday we got
Texas poll Wednesday we got major
Richard ojetta uh Thursday we got Fred
Wellman coming back I'm super excited to
have a major and Fred come back to the
show I know Fred wants to talk about the
ndaa because he was in the military so
that uh the military authorization act a
National Defense authorization excuse me
is very important to him and I'm sure
major it will be too so I'm sure we'll
be talking about those issues um with
those two this week and then of course
tomorrow's Tuesdays Taco Tuesday great
Tuesday and Texas fall Tuesday so don't
miss it stay tuned same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
foreign
everybody back up I'm back with another
song